hello kelly first of all very very
good thank you for agreeing to do this little
this little interview a guy you way
can you tell us who you are
and what you are working on that's fine yes
thank you very much and liliane  yes so i
am kelly picard french
lecturer at jean monnet university
near lyon and i am in public law so
it is more particularly in public law
i have been working on the notions of
damages for about ten years now  history and
transitional justice will have the opportunity to
come back to this, I devoted my
doctoral thesis to these questions in particular, namely the
question of the responsibility of the state
in reparation for historical damage
and then besides that  so I work
as part of my
research work on everything related to the protection
of rights and freedoms
justice and reparation mechanisms in
post-conflict situations therefore
from ipic mansle and
truth-rec commission  conciliating
the different forms of reparation
that can be envisaged in this context that
they come out a little from an
ordinary legal framework and then I also had
the opportunity, moreover, to go
a little bit into the field to
to test the theories that game developed
within the framework of my research
in particular in the
Central African context in bangui in the central
African republic lever could
participate a little bit in the process of
reconstruction of the state in any case of
post conflict these last years
here
thank you
and to return  a bit directly in
the heart of the matter you said that you are
working on the on the issue of
creating historical judici can you
tell us exactly what that is
what you mean by that yes
very gladly then
historical prejudice first  thing you should
know in fact that doesn't exist
legally it's a first difficulty at
first obstacle it doesn't exist so
it was my concern to conceptualize it
by  what if legally it does
not exist it seems to me that the
social phenomena that we can feel the
ten historical them are very present and
therefore I found that it was necessary
to conceptualize this idea then
what is it  what I hear about
historical
judici schematically in broad strokes
is the idea of situations of extre
e violence whether extreme in their sever
ty or in their mass character becom
s extreme that have not found answe
s in terms of  justice or
reparation and therefore over time
the state has not provided a
satisfactory
or sufficient response in terms of justice, therefore
justice in the broad sense which includes
precisely these questions of reparation of
truth etc.
and that has created this effect in the  a society
of resentment frustration anger a
certain form of animosity or even
mistrust which is transmitted from generation
to generation and who knows what is
observed, this is also reinforced from
generation to generation until  u to
potentially
explode in the future from a
bomb of hormones it is françoise sironi
who is a psychologist who speaks of
dormant bombs in society when we do
not take ourselves seriously in fact these
phenomena of violence are very serious
and that we actually prefer it ben ali
and under the rug and to get
rid of it let's move on well it
's in the past and it's these
social phenomena so my concern here
was  try to give a
concrete and legal reality to this phenomenon
and try to take me into
account in
the courts so that we can
finally provide an answer in terms of
reparation and justice to the people
who have been  therefore in fact doubly
victims because they were victims
at the time of the violence victims of
exactions noun typically to everything that
is
against humanity genocide
war crimes therefore serious violence and then
they are then doubly victims
by being a little deigned  in their qu
bedridden victim but never being recognized
as such and in that the state
never recognizes their suffering and
tells me that they have lived and suffered so
that's it reinforces once again here is
this feeling of injustice we double
injustice
both in the state that let
the violence happen and the six committed themselves and
also in the state that did not do
justice
to this violence
that is what I mean by
saying historical
thank you very much and from the  Suddenly the crimes
of colonization and the crimes
of slavery
fall into this category where
as the crimes of slavery have
been considered as crimes
against humanity it is no longer necessary to
resort to this category
then
I have just included the crimes of
colonization and skirmishes in
this category historical damage
because therefore there is indeed this double
dimension finally the historical damage
why historical because there is this
double phenomenon of history there is
history as there was a one-
off event marking a
historical event which generated a prejudice and
then there are the historical facts in the
Latin diffuse time which creates this
historical dimension therefore this double meaning
of the term therefore old wii prejudices
such as the  colonization of the slave
could fall into this category there
then after -6 by making a question
really a pure - legal and technical
there are questions of limitation
of interest to act which will come into question
is made up of the obstacles before
legal actions
perhaps we will come back to this later,
but typically yes, colonization
like slavery
constitute historical damage
insofar as
they have been characterized by
extremely serious violence and for the
French case, for example, with regard
to slavery  colonial or natural war
they did not receive a
sufficient
satisfactory response in terms of justice
so we would return typical  ment in these
situations
is to soon understand what
is actually gained by using this
category of historical harm
rather than that of crimes
against humanity
ok so we are good question finally 6 the
fact is that
in fact there c  it is then I reflect,
not to say nonsense, the idea of
ical prejudice which is also underlying this
t is the idea in fact of a prejudice that they
re trans
enerational it is a little bit the i
ea that  I defend and which has a little
complicated for lawyers to receive
in a very Cartesian spirit
but it is the idea that in fact these
violences this phenomenon finally the moment
of war crimes of crimes
against humanity it did not have  surely
repercussions only on the people who
were present at the time of this
violence,
but it also had repercussions
on the descendants of these people,
the descendants of these direct victims
and had phenomena when we actually study
psychology or even  the
sociology or even now in fact
the neurosciences there is more and
more research which is struggling to show that there
is a transmission of trauma whether
it is sometimes even in the
genetic heritage or in the
psychological heritage there really is a form
of transmission of trauma  traumas of
injustices repercussions over
time and therefore also read through the
historical prejudices it would
also recognize the potential effects
on all successive generations
and also better
understand society as it is today
and the phenomena  social today and
that trans generational prejudices
in fact expects to be a little
more
taken into account is considered it is in
particular certain lawyers before the
international criminal court
who are trying to
gain access to the question of
transgenerational prejudices  because it is
particularly in the
Katanga sphere concerning the
Democratic Republic of the Congo
the neck  r agreed to recognize that it
was a question of crimes
against humanity war crimes the court
accepted to note transgenerational damage
therefore the fact that the
descendants the children of the people
who knew his wars his attacks
these events suffered damage
psychological after
-effects sometimes physical after-effects
we could not develop but
also for a
month the field of study that
I also like in these questions
there it is the case of rwanda because if
they act in fact war rapes
we see  that the consequences in any
case on future generations it is
particularly
evocative because we have women who
have contracted diseases from women
who have given birth to these rapes there and therefore
the effects are on future generations
they are particularly serious and
martin  and we observe them very well
but there it does not prevent I come back to the
international criminal court
it noted these damages it did not
not denied it recognized them but
refused to repair them
it considered that
the causal link was not
sufficiently
proven it was difficult to
really prove that the pathologies
suffered by young children today
mental disorders etc.  were
directly and certainly attributable to the
fact that their parents suffered this
violence m so it is the
causal link that has been somewhat lacking but
we are moving forward little by little is
therefore just to respond to a phase
attacked his departure this  that I made a
little
detour but the difference with the crime
against humanity is that the substance
against humanity we only take into
consideration the direct victims,
therefore the first rank of the victims who
are affected by this violence
the idea would be to see the
global photograph and all the repercussions on
society because massive violence
of the war type crimes against humanity
does not only have repercussions on the
people  rsons who have experienced these phenomena there
but it has repercussions in my opinion
and explosions
explosion much more important
than
stupor it is super clear
and from the neck is what from so
let's imagine that we manage to go in
front of the end  I don't know if I will be
before a national
court, international court, which would be
possible to
have a state
like France recognized in the event of 20 of
its two crimes that were committed
in the former colonies,
yes then
seemingly simple question but it's
complex there are many things
there are many things because therefore
there is both therefore the question of
responsibility so here we are going to talk about
responsibility talent bias I want to
come back to that and then to the  times the
question of before which jurisdiction
yes indeed there is national
just one word is therefore certain
responsibility is claimed me I
focused on the idea of a respo
sibility  of the state to seek
responsibility last heap because we
can also seek the responsibility
of individuals individually 1
whether private persons
citizens or
natural persons but representing
public authority such as a mayor or a
president the  republic but it
seems to me that precisely that does not fit
with the idea of the historical president becau
e it is a succession of respo
sibilities there is not only one perso
who was responsible for all that
t is it is  a chain of
responsibilities
there is this idea of
ical continuity and everyone has a little bit o
their share so me it doesn't bother me that
t bothered me it's
lso besides that these
mechanisms already exist to solicit and engag
the responsibility of  an individual
already exists so what I
wanted to dig into a little is that we
can engage the responsibility of a state
there it is already a little more
complicated because from a criminal point of view
it is not possible to engage the
penal responsibility of a state it is
not possible because in the
criminal field there is this idea of moral element in fa
t there is an idea of intention to engage for
xample the responsibil
ty of  of an individual in a genocide, for
example, you have to be able to demonstrate
before the judge that this
individual intends to exterminate a people, but in
fact these inputs contradict the
principle of a state because it is not
not a person who thinks as
such so we cannot demonstrate
the intention of a state legally in
any case even if we could question
in the current state
criminal responsibility and state it is
not compatible so these are
responsibilities of public order
and therefore public which served the entire
community of the state the
education complex in hesdin rémy I have a
small question is what the
criminal liability
of a company can be
the criminal liability of a  many
times good  question
[Music]
skills sap the game
I don't care this way new
couple and their passage no but that
but I have a little doubt but afterwards there
is always the difference between private and
public and
it is private a company so
the in fact since we are in
public law the state it is direct
derogatory always in fact therefore less
well even there are things that it is
possible a right price but it is not
always possible in law  public but
I admit that I make you happy with
nonsense
but to come back
to the public question of the
collective responsibility of the state
at that moment so it is
indeed possible to operate the state
both internally, nationally and  on the
international level there are two
possibilities
on the internal level what we have in any
case a francis and mechanisms of
liability for fault or without
fault both are possible so it is for
fault there is a slightly aggravating factor
administrative law
and then  if there is the international level,
we have a little giggles, for example, at
actions before the european court
of human rights,
then possibly before the
united nations human rights committee, but
that is not a jurisdiction  as
such the united nations human rights committee
pronounces
recommendations but it does not have this
binding action of sanctions so
if a little bit limited effectiveness
but so there are possibilities to note
so later  i was talking about the icc
the international criminal court that's
one for kimi is only competent to
incur individual responsibilities
or not states they
are people for prosecution
before the icc
and therefore suddenly yes if we were to
prosecute the
colonial crimes of france to
what would be what is possible
finally I imagine that it depends a little on
which space but
finally whether it is where the
crimes were committed and whether it is
if we act a  at the national regional
or international level
yes then indeed we have several
options even if they are not all
I am of an optimistic temperament but
here I admit that the game doubts if we are a
little lucid of the probabilities
of action in all  case its
international level if we start on the
international level we do not have a lot of
leverage because therefore we
eventually have the high committee of human
rights of the united nations but as
I know one essentially formulates
recommendations there  there are not necessarily
2.2 binding means
and apart from that we therefore have the
European Court of Human Rights puts
so Algeria is not a member of
the European Council so that would
imply Franco-French action even if it
could  be initiated by activists
by associations or by
descendants of victims it is
quite possible
there is moreover at the moment
is moreover the decision should be made
soon a year ago  action
before the European court of
human rights relating to the reparation of
French colonial slavery
on the basis of this famous law the
taubira law 2001 which recognizes
colonial slavery as a crime
against humanity in fact this group is  is it
the international movement for
reparations
a collective which has initiated
legal actions in france to seek
reparation because in fact they have
underlined the fact that we have we have
dedicate a criminal qualification we have
recognized that there was a  crime
against humanity but we got out of no
reparation on our own, which is all the same rather
rather particular because we see that
they write but we do not repair
so they have taken legal
action before the French courts
each time  times they were dismissed and therefore
they reached the
European Court of Human Rights where he
tries to put forward their arguments
the court even if good generally it
is not very at the  daring on this kind
of questions a little bit sensitive but
it can be a way to try
to leverage action to put a little bit
of pressure also diplomatically so
to see what happens
we must also point out a difficulty
in fact  it is the temporal competence
of its courts in fact all these
international courts they are
of fairly recent creation
and for example the european court
of human rights france has not ratified
the statute so it has accepted a fact
that the competence  of the court in 1974 that
means that everything that happened
before 1974 the court cannot
know about it for the if we take the case of
the ICC the international criminal court
it came into force in 2002 the same
thing every  facts which are prior
to 2002 the court cannot know them
there we have a real problem also vis-à-
vis the question of the Algerian war
is that these are old facts and
therefore the jurisdiction of the courts is
limited
to  where in fact
well in fact I try to go through
this roundabout door of transgenerational prejudice
and to recognize the
ass and that even if
it is done in the old way the
repercussions on individuals
are still present and there are
always consequences  of these actions
is therefore there are always damages
that are suffered today but it is a
bit difficult to have the courts accept
but therefore there is this barrier in fact
so much for her which makes it really nice
when you don't  there is no
retroactive application a court does not want to
take up facts that took place before
it was created so that is a
problem
there is the possibility of
creating institutions that are a little bit
specialized as we see it  for
example, for the
international criminal tribunal for the former yugoslavia or
for rwanda, we had created
specific haddock jurisdictions which will
deal with past events,
but we will create them for this purpose.  to but
that therefore also requires
an international consensus and a
political will to create them so that
's on the
international level on the national level
there remains this possibility of
seizing the courts internally
we also remain on a question at a
small  little of the
Franco French blow did not sagna this even if
there is not this idea which would be
important of
cooperation or between Algeria and France
we remain face to face with it and the current debates
in fact the subject not a little according to our
French prism but good that  can be a
way to move things forward in
terms of reparation it is necessary to manage to
find it is all the difficulty the good
legal basis to justify it of a
prejudice and the causal link in
fact for the responsibility it is necessary to
demonstrate three things it
you have to demonstrate a causal event you demonstrate
damage
and a causal link between the causal event
and the police and that's often
where it's difficult it's to
demonstrate this  e sure and
certain causality between between the two and this is
where the courts
rush into this path to
evacuate with the back of the hand this type of
litigation
the past on the carpet still a blur
to
also if I understand you correctly
the alternative would indeed be
twice to try to
mobilize this category of historical damage as much as possible
yes finally it would be a bit simple
the outcome so yes
it is necessarily it is in this
concern that I j  I designed things
after there is everything that is in fact in it
but when I worked on my thesis
on these questions I was quickly
confronted I considered all the
possible liability mechanisms
I saw that  even if each time it
lacks a little bit to be able to
get there but that still constitutes
obstacles and as I say finally the
lawyers are Cartesian square so
all these things there it is the fact that
they have  impact on
bodies and minds  generations
later it's something that will take
a little bit of time to
do its job so there is another
possibility too which is not to
resort to the way I'm going to dictionary
at all,
that is to say that in fact it  you have to
ask yourself the question what do you want
if what you want is a form of
reparation but which results in
perhaps official public recognition
, perhaps part of public policies
whatever it is  whether it's a bit
of positive discrimination whether it
's access to care whether it's
to ensure in fact there is not
necessarily no need to go through
the judicial process and so that's
good that I am  interested in
transitional justice because in fact
it is the very essence of the raison d'être
of transitional justice
it is a justice that in the face of the obstacles
of
the jurisdictional environment and the rigidity
of the law and well will circumvent one  will
go through various doors
and we will put in  place of
para-judicial systems which borrows
a little bit from the ceremonial justice
but which knows
side in parallel with the
soft institutional justice typically the
truth commission reconciliation like
that can be done in south africa or
elsewhere
from where also there is a  option which is
quite interesting to dig spades is
really starting to come back quite a bit
it's what we call the courts
of opinion the courts of opinion it
was put in place as early as, for example, with
regard to environmental law
the German Saintot stands in fact
it is a court of opinion so he that
the law the environment was not
sufficiently developed we do not
yet have a consensus on crime deco side
and it is good we are doing a simulation
court have recreated  all the
ceremonial property court with experts with
public figures and we act
as if we were judging the facts in
question it was also done with
regard to the comfort women
r  comfort
during the second world war these
korean women who was used
by japan to satisfy the needs of
japanese soldiers in the
face of the reluctance of justice to
recognize the fate that has been reserved for
these families have set up bonuses
or opinion  so in fact they acted
as if he had judged
the authors whether individual or
state the emperor in this case
according to rules of justice either that they
borrow from existing rights or that
they invent to show how the
law  should evolve and in the face of this
effect, after diplomatic and
political and symbolic pressure that is also very low,
there are other avenues also here that
can come out a little from what
existed on the institutional jurisdictional side
which is sometimes very
rigid and which does not  is not
flexible enough to understand these situations
which are a little out of legal category
to
question is what it is
is what these courts of opinion have
allowed to  e to move the lines
yes yes still the courts
allowed to move the lines
or slowly
slowly as regards for
example the comfort women they
have gradually
been done for decades but it
begins to obtain a form of
recognition on
the part of the institutions of the planet
it remains very thin but in any case there
is such an
international awareness on these questions there
it is also the goal is to shed
light on these questions there and
that others  to seize it only wholesalers movement
concerning for example monsanto in
environmental law yes there
was more concrete percussion and
also the questions on the environment
the consensual and it is a little
easier perhaps  be to carry them but there
is a whole heap there are tons and
tons of experiences of the courts
of opinion of which I do not
understand all the repercussions sufficiently
thereafter to know if
systemat  Only it is followed by effect
but it is also finally it remains a
true limit of the right also even the
situational finger it is subject to
political will and therefore
even if we even have a
classic court decision or a
court decision a little more simulate according
to more innovative simple processes and
well if the political power does not
want to follow and does not want to
give enough effects decision
remains difficult to constrain it it
remains master in its kingdom  so so it's
still quite difficult to move
the lines and it's time that is
powerless in lille it's in these
mechanisms never
for there to make a last little
parallel with regard to the second
world war we had a lot at the beginning
recognized the individual responsibilities
of the authors for example
with the courts of nuremberg
condemned some of the authors but to
recognize the collective
and global responsibility of the state it was necessary to att  end
his life without france 2009 2009 so a
first court decision in france
recognizes the responsibility of
france in the deportation of jews from
france so 60 years what then anyway
it was finally about the holocaust
and therefore the  time really is an
important element even if it never goes
fast enough I understand it well
but when you see clearly we are a bit
in this period there too the
Algerian war it will be 60 years soon as
the prediction so we  is perhaps in
this pivotal set there that's why we
feel that things are starting to stir it
is perhaps its 60 years there there is perhaps an element
of generation that
precisely makes it start to stand out  and we
can perhaps hope that things will change
a little
very well it's great
listening I look forward to the discussion
we will be able to have
with both activists
and students on these subjects yes
I  hope this can shed some light
and give some clues  reflection
yes thank you very much
thank you liliane